Every day I watch the weatherman on TV.
Knowing about the weather is important to me.
I want to know if the wind will blow.
I want to know if it will rain.
I want to know if it will snow.
How is the weather today?
The weatherman says warm with showers.
I will wear my raincoat. I will go fishing with Dad.
How is the weather today?
The weatherman says it will be stormy. I will play in the house.
The weatherman says it will be hot.
I will go to the beach.
How is the weather today?
The weatherman says it will be cool and windy.
I will wear my jacket. I will fly my kite.
How is the weather today?
The weatherman says it will be cold and icy.
I will wear my hat and coat.
How is the weather today?
The weatherman says it will snow.
I will make a snowman.
The weather changes with the seasons.
I like changing weather.
I can wear different clothes.
I can do different things.